here with our very own ross matthews
i'm back everybody hi hi miss you
i miss you too cute look we always
coordinate totally on accident this is
banana i know
i talk about it all the time i mean are
your pants navy their navy i just got
them
they were on clearance thank you so much
for noticing we don't plan these things
it just shows
that we're aligned and spiritual
and patako yes yes
ross i understand that you did something
special recently to get into
the holidays yeah well you know i'm
holly jolly uh i always have been so i
did a couple things and one of them i
can actually talk about on daytime
television
i visited the elf on the shelf magical
holiday journey in
la and i know when you hear los angeles
you don't exactly think winter
wonderland but wait
just wait until you see this place it is
a fun
festive drive-through experience right
you and your family get in the car
and you're shrunken down to elf size
okay which i didn't even know they could
do
and then you try to round up as much
christmas spirit as
magic as possible to save christmas got
it i
love this and by the way frankie my
daughter is gonna freak because the elf
on the shelf is like
that's her thing well take a look
because i might have just run into like
the biggest
celebrity of them all what oh my god
okay let's roll the tape
hey drew i'm here in los angeles at the
elf on the shelf magical holiday journey
it's like a show
that you drive through which means i got
to decorate my car just a little bit
what i'm festive all right here we go
they work for santa yes we do
very cool i work for drew barrymore oh
that's nice so close to the same thing
oh okay scan my car for christmas spirit
i promise you're gonna find some
here we go okay
that thing's broken i don't know i am so
holly jolly i am hojo
oh my god i'm going through a shrinking
tunnel can it help me get to my goal
weight
this is insane hi everybody hi
you have a letter for dancing dear santa
i'd like a
zero calorie wine
oh my god i love this hi
something fishy is going on here wow
look at this yeah but you just have one
okay
just one that's all you get oh my gosh
look at this
wowza that takes balls
come on pick up the pace i'm in a flurry
merry christmas santa i'm such a huge
fan and i'm a fan of yours ross so good
to see you oh i'm freaking
out right now santa knows my name santa
you know if you ever have a day off or
you don't want to just kick it by the
pool i'd be happy to be your understudy
well i might have a little room in my
sleigh
high five santa i don't know if you're
ready for this big bowl of jelly
full of jelly is the big requirement
okay good i'm in will you say hi to drew
oh hello truth so good to see you
merry christmas girl
you owe me big
merry christmas
you guys it's totally neat
merry christmas to all and to all
a good night
yeah that's a wrap on santa how do i get
down from here
you know what i want for christmas a
step stool
[Applause]
oh hi dougie it's ross hi
wait a minute how did you change so fast
it was like a nassar pic
nascar pit crew during that piece they
were like
but look don't i look great oh my gosh
you look so good will you give me a ho
ho ho ho
[Laughter]
ho ho
oh i have drew's news coming up i'll be
back i'll be looking normal